hey welcome back
riffin with Griffin thank you for
listening thank you for continuing to
stay on the journey so once again I
always say it's a special episode
because I have somebody special coming
in this time I'm completely wrong this
one he ain't [ __ ]
[Laughter]
one of my best friends in the world
family to me like a little brother since
I first met him give it up for the very
funny and handsome nice nice is here in
the game give it up for a Matt rife
everybody that's that's flat I had the
nicest hair I know you don't listen to
my podcast cuz you're not supportive you
know you ain't [ __ ] I technically not a
millennial what are you talking about
Millennials are like 25 to like 30
okay so what is your generation we're
called like a generation like X or
something a generation generation it's
something it's not good whatever it is
it's worse than millennial generation we
don't have a we don't have a generation
well anyways what happens is you know
I've been in search of a theme song for
like this to start just the beginning of
the show and every week I think oh this
is gonna be that this is the one and
then people keep sending in to keep
sending them in so here's one
they keep topping it so here's a new one
now this is from Marty B cuz he's got a
weird last name you'll see it on the
screen right now it's bruger man or
Brooklyn just Marty be Marty be sounds
better sound like a good rap name but
here's a Marty feeb
[Music]
piano action
[Music]
feel like we're on a cruise ship here it
is enjoy the show well there it is man
so you finally here finally on the
podcast finally here man what episode is
this what number is this I'm not sure
but it's in the 20s you're gonna be in
the 20s let's just start from the
beginning so you you're from
unfortunately from Ohio you know I
remember cuz you were like 14 and then
you were like sending messages out to
every comic that was coming in into Ohio
uh-huh just like messaging and tweet net
people and stuff and like I like so many
comics like like who was some of the
comics that you like reached out to and
and they got back to you in the
beginning I was 15 I just started
stand-up and it was when Twitter was
still like accessible like you can still
communicate with people because not
everybody had a couple hundred thousand
followers you can send a DM to like
Ashton Kutcher and he can see he might
see it up on there were DL Hughley who
gave me my first guest spot like ever I
was like four months in the stand-up
definitely should not have been doing
this yeah and then it was finesse
Mitchell and yourself were like the same
time and then DeRay Davis after that in
Ralphie May Wow Ralphie May let me do my
first theater when I was like autumn all
the black car
[Laughter]
so really do who gave you your first Wow
yeah like my home club but Columbus Pony
ball in there just let me do like five
to seven and up top and of course it was
trash but he was like he invited me to
stay the entire weekend like my grandpa
came with me to the shows and stuff and
I remember you were obviously your thing
your weigh in was always being like the
white kid in the black club it wasn't
intentional I've been asked a bunch of
times like how did you find yourself in
that kind of like market audience I
think it's just because like black
comedians are more but they're more apt
to sharing a spotlight or whatever like
that like they're they're totally okay
helping you out like a lot of white
comics can be stingy like black comics
like hey come do my room I can put you
up I will take a chance on you like
white comics don't do that as often at
least relax
that's your experience that's great and
then so you yeah but you were like I
remember your awesome woman be a
Pittsburgh and he took the bus to put
her I'd already seen your cook like
crazy like you know I had a music you oh
yeah it was like so black your act was
so it was like blah but the black is and
then I knew it wasn't gonna go well
dude you set me up sold out you let me
take a bus to my doom was trying to do
that stuff but these white people I was
like I was in the green room no TV on
the whole time you're on stage just like
I know yes when your teeth were messed
up Ohio teeth for sure I got to put a
picture of that up absolutely do not if
you do that I'm posting a picture of you
in your tracks ooh okay alright your
teeth my tracksuit Oh same thing you
ain't [ __ ] I dare you
and then look at you now so you went
from you know talked about you know you
when did you want to be a car
Mikell like when you were you started
young like not everybody only a few
people even start that you know even
have the ability to reach out to people
like that so like what it you know you
wanted to be a comic I I started when I
was fifteen and a half but I think what
it kind of clicked with me when I was
fourteen is that's when I was like
really kind of fell in love with like
comedy central this is back then like
kind of everybody had a half hour
special and I would just like Golden
Arrow yeah yeah and I would just watch
it every single night at my two biggest
influences like Dane Cook and Dave
Chappelle like I fell in love with those
guys and like I just I wanted to do what
they did and it's it's so weird it's it
wasn't a prominent experience but just
the timing of it it just it felt like
faked kind of I remember I had just
watched day one of Dane Cook specials
and I was like super into into comedy
and the next day in school it was like
the very beginning of the day class is
all kind of filing in my friend Amanda
was like what do you want to do when you
grow up which is a intense question for
a 7th grader it was a long time seventh
grade so I smashed trust me as soon as
she sue she asked that I was like I
think I want to be a comedian I'm like
as soon as I said that not a second way
but my teacher came in the door was like
we're doing a talent show and I was like
well I I have to first mom yeah it was
such an inappropriate set like the
teachers were like okay that's enough
time Matthew thank you and then I got to
see Dane Cook live at Nationwide Arena
in Columbus and that finally was like
the last straw of life this is what I
wanted to do this looks not to full
circle that you just you're you're doing
some tour dates with Dane right now yeah
yeah I'm on tour with him right now
we've done six shows so far on the tool
and they've been unreal right we're
doing like 3,000 plus series every
single night it's it's so much fun who's
audiences are great yeah but isn't it
crazy though that like if you cut back
to like 14 year old Matt mm-hmm and
you're thinking about doing shows with
Dane it would have been like yeah cut to
20 something-year-old Matt you're out
there with Daniel you're kind of like oh
this is cool but
your perspective changes when you like
and only in ten years - they're like 10
years from that what I'm gonna be 33
that feels like around the corner but if
I think back to you okay so you're so
you're for you to find out you know my
birthday's coming up my birthday's on
March 12 I know this is coming out or
not before that um yeah I'm just trying
to think like like you when I first saw
you I was like because you know Stan
that's not made for kids it's absolutely
not like what and you were playing on
like you're being like oh I'm the Justin
Bieber of comedy like I'm in these like
[Music]
eight that up though I don't regret that
in I'm glad I cut it off when I did it
was in like my BIOS also yeah it didn't
say Widger on your son Michael rapping
boards nephew I know you had like some
teachers that said you weren't gonna
make it right absolutely dude I had a
biology teacher name is Bradley - [ __ ]
that woman if she hears my hopes a huge
fan of yours [ __ ] miss Bradley first of
all I didn't need to know a single thing
about biology oh here we go
and then I was just I was always getting
in trouble in her class I was always
cracking jokes and not paying attention
to a subject I knew I wasn't gonna use
and I remember one day she was yelling
at me in front of the entire class and
was just like you think it's all fun and
games being funny in class let me tell
you nobody's ever gotten anywhere being
funny that's not gonna pay the bills and
I was like oh she was like I
you're gonna end up working the rest of
your life at McDonald's and which I
respond which I responded in front of
the entire class wolf I work at
McDonald's my entire life I'm eventually
climb my way up the ladder and be making
way more than a teacher's salary
I got me four days but cut to now and
she actually might have been right you
were broke she would have called that
I'd have a little bit more respect that
actually sucks but it's like you just
you just had those moments man in life
where people act like you know they act
like they know but see one thing I know
of you that you know how you're just one
of the most frustrating people I've ever
met in my mid-30s from a kid like I
remember one of my favorite moments is
you talking about I said you ever go to
museums or something you like
I don't like art are stupid that's him
little punk-ass kid art is dumb and then
remember I said to you I said would you
like a shoes shoes and sneakers you look
it of course so that's and now now
museums like it's gonna change so much
kids give it time yeah give it time
eating vegetables now things change
it's so fast sometimes you never why
does it always have to be old [ __ ]
thing where he likes old chicks why do
you like old chicks the last four you
dated are always way older than you and
what do I always say
it's not but you don't listen it's
different this time it's different to
start I do it's yeah please explain to
me why you like you know it's
frustrating
nice frustrating teen years older than
you chick you know it's so first you
know matter what I'm about to say you're
gonna go oh my god no it's not gonna
like work for you come on I
I like the maturity I like the level of
messiness I'm talking about you know I
care don't rile thank you for listening
to
okay so you like mature okay you like
mature I like my I don't I don't think I
have mommy issues my mom and I are fine
yeah
doesn't mean you don't have mommy issues
you every okay let's go
one was 29 when you were what 20 18 18
29 they were 45 40 it's like what and
they all don't work out because of why
we're at different places in our life
you know what you at different places
and you like I don't wanna I don't I
want to be with someone who motivates me
to get to get to where they are like it
but somebody who has their own place and
has their own job and that can take care
of themself that motivates it inspires
me to want to step it up as a man and
grow as an adult faster I like that I
don't like I don't like going out to the
club's every night I don't want somebody
who wants to be at the clubs there in
that I don't want a girl other chicks
you know there's other chicks in LA that
I haven't met anything because you know
why because your ass is always at the
club and what club how do you know all
the chicks who wants to go oh my god me
let me calm down how do you know that
every chick wants to go to the club
because any young girl I've met under
the age of 25 in LA wants to go to club
every single night they want to know
what celebrity they can be around they
want to know what what VIP list they can
get a who's table they can be where are
you meeting these chicks anywhere in LA
Wow I'm like we're tell me we're Trader
Joe's I don't know like Wells do you
meet people we're on the street oh my
god you're so infuriating this because I
haven't met these people I don't doubt
that they're out there but I have you
don't try to meet them of course I'm not
gonna rush into a relationship all the
time
[Applause]
you're not trying to rush into it that's
all you ever do I should put the camera
on me then then what he does is he gives
you these relationships I say it's not
gonna work and then he's at my door
crying how many times you've been at my
door crying over some old [ __ ] huh how
many times just like like this to that
like it hurts cry I just first of all ok
let's go backwards okay you you come to
LA actually when you came to LA first
you you came and you stayed with me I
took you around to all the clubs you
know you need [ __ ] didn't even
appreciate it inside did you like an
entire you know what you're just like a
white girl just go to the club I didn't
realize the severity of it till I moved
here Oh people wait four days to try to
get an open mic spot hello and I'm just
walking you in on my appreciate it later
you're right you're right I did notice I
didn't understand who offer vilage that
was thank you thank you but you did that
and you but what I appreciate about what
you did is like you just left everything
and we're getting back to the old [ __ ]
thing but we gonna leave it up to it so
you uh you came here you were like I'm
just gonna do it right and you left your
girlfriend back in oh yeah I had a
girlfriend back in Ohio who was older
was a butterface dude she was very
pretty she was an Ohio 9 for sure yeah
but that's the la touche because she's
gonna listen she was a sweet sweet girl
she took my virginity and I owe her but
but wait she wasn't that much older than
you know I was I was 17 she was 19 oh
that's right that's not bad that was
baby steps compared to late compared to
like the grandma's you've been dating
he could call his girlfriend's Nana
so you Aaron never laughs out loud by
the way okay so you were with her and
then she was but she was a small-town
girl
mm-hmm and she wanted you to be a
small-town guy yes you had Hollywood
dreams yeah do my my life some music
video like it was so weird she she is of
course we talked about she wanted to
move out to LA and like a year so don't
you can gain money of course that never
happens all we do is fight on the phone
every single day cuz neither was trusted
each other yeah you at all
that's the real problem - this is the
time he's master type of dude that's
like if like she got a picture in a
bikini on Instagram all I used to be
that not anymore not anymore but I used
to be bad with absolutely and rightfully
so and [ __ ] still not [ __ ] but at least
I have teeth now Oh God expensive taste
Spencer so you alright yeah she was
gonna move out here like after a year we
ended up breaking up or whatever but
yeah I graduated high school early I'm
right I was thinking I came out here
just down on your couch like I take the
California officials that's right you
came to do yeah like just for like a
week yeah but Yugi was it it's the it's
like the chess piece I think which is
like the California proficiency exam I
get this is what I was told by this I
did the second but I guess they I had to
take it twice because I missed one
question on a math education yo
everybody else got a calculator I only
failed by one question not using a
calculator I didn't bring the right one
yeah so I came out here took that and
apparently that's the it's the exact
equivalent of a high school diploma
because I guess and in California what I
was told is you take a test to graduate
and Ohio it's like a credit system kind
of like college oh but I guess in
California take a test saying you know
you learned everything you need to know
well that's if you cuz if you if you
weren't in high school you didn't do a
good ya didn't have it you just decided
to leave early that's just like the GED
I guess yeah right so you did that
because you were bad yeah and I took
that that passing statement back to my
school oh hi oh they're like I will like
you don't have to be here anymore
technically graduated and then I moved
out to LA State on your house for like
two more weeks
my friend moved out here and then I was
on his couch for like a year and yeah it
was a lot of what was the first thing
that you were like damn I'm actually in
Hollywood like I'm doing it um I'd say
just walk into the Laugh Factory every
night because I was right on like Santa
Monica in Fairfax remember that Whole
Foods and I can walk to all of the clubs
I did so much walking there about a mile
you were like right occasion
WeHo so you were real popular back then
oh yeah dude it was some guy to do
[ __ ] I pull his dick out of the
laundromat one time it was a dude's a
bus stops being like are you for rent
like how much do you cost and I always
regret not asking how much really just
doing stand-up like that was like okay
so you wanted to be a stand-up so then
you hear about the Laugh Factory you
meet Dane Cook and all these people yeah
I remember you introduced me to all that
my first words were oh [ __ ] like I
couldn't I could it was the first time
I've ever been like starstruck making
somebody well it is it is crazy like now
we're like really really good yeah yeah
it still blows my mind be out doing
stand-up and going all the clubs was
just like it felt moving till I felt
like home like I never felt like I was
supposed to be in Ohio like it was just
just nothing going on it's the same life
plan for everybody back there you know
you got a height you go to school in
this in a small hometown you get
somebody pregnant yeah then you graduate
then you get married and you work get
her pregnant again
get married get divorced get your
neighbor pray it's the same setup for
everybody that didn't appeal to my
always felt like bored so moving out
here I felt like what I was supposed to
do even if even if it wasn't for this
career I wasn't supposed to be living
back there I got yet so when you so you
know now you're in LA and then you're
doing standard which was difficult for
you at first I know I remembered this
like you know like stand-up wasn't it
wasn't as easy as it had come to you
young I'm because I got finally like
young
people doing stand-up they don't even
understand cuz you're just out there
like just being you just trying to think
of anything that's fun but and that's
what people that let they're not
necessarily laughing at what you're
saying they're laughing at you like a
court jester yeah yeah then when it when
was it for you that you were like oh man
this is actually harder than I thought
I'd say about like twenty twenty
twenty-one that's when I really started
to be like okay I'm not a kid kid
anymore I'm still young I'm still very
young and like an anomaly age wise but I
wasn't I didn't have the given kind of
gimmick let's give this kid the benefit
of the doubt people will start to be
like okay I need to hear some [ __ ] yeah
but I'm glad that happen because you can
coast and be a happy comic for the rusty
eleven people make careers out of that
but I'm glad that I was forced to know
how to do that by people like you being
like okay I see you having good shows
but like you're not funny
I do keeps it real no but you come along
you know what we just did a show
together like you know at the Irvine
improv yeah and I was watching you and I
thought to myself but I I remember
watching you and I was like I start I
was laughing and I caught myself and I
was like oh [ __ ] I'm actually having I'm
enjoying that cutaway right that I don't
worry I'm views expressed by know I feel
comfortable now yeah yeah but much more
I can I can go onstage and them in any
older material that I'm used to doing
now I can weave in and out of bits now
like I can message the crowd I feel
comfortable on set I can be nervous
before I go on but I guess soon as I
step on I I feel I feel fine I feel like
there's nothing anybody can yell out
it's gonna catch me off guard
I feel comfortable my material and that
it's starting to relate to me and
actually start to talk about me a little
bit which is nice it's a it's kind of
therapeutic and away yeah well that's
that's what I always say too it's like
you go onstage no matter what's going on
in your life you have to go on there and
entertain so you just take these
emotions and you're up there just like
letting it out they don't even know
yeah it's a really cool opportunity as
well but like it's it's a fun way for me
to kind of be like to kind of prove
people wrong because usually when I walk
on stage most people don't like me
immediately like oh my I guess my
[ __ ] face
dude I I can't tell you how many times
I've been right for comments shaking
that it's definitely too pretty for gay
look at this what calm he's supposed to
look like this is what comedy supposed
to look like not this [ __ ] pretty
[ __ ] right here I'm so glad the
lights so you I've had so many shows
that like what I always go like shake
hands after the show and stuff thanks
for coming i that's so minute do is be
like when you walked on stage I don't
want to like you really [ __ ] good so
I'm actually talking about some [ __ ] and
you know I'm not you got to overcome
that now when was the first time okay so
when did that become a thing for you
like when did you know like when did you
know that like the combination of being
like naturally attractive and then also
performing was gonna like you know have
panties soakin did you have you
awakening of like oh I can smash a lot
probably like within like the last two
years I you start to get a little famous
I used to tell you stop [ __ ] your
face I mean everybody's loud my DM now
but you don't understand a floodgate of
like fourteen-year-old dm's you just
have yeah don't don't think you have a
chance all the time what our small 14 is
way too young for you yeah I know but
you know 35 and up and then you got a
chance with man you oh my gosh you
wouldn't believe like the gross comments
I'll get from like like
fourteen-year-old girls like where are
your parents
I know that's yes or they don't know
different generation
it's disgusting I'm like you can't say
this [ __ ] on my page like makes me look
weird
but yeah but you but yeah but didn't you
started like you know you broke up with
your girl you single then two years
later not you 18 you know 19 yeah what
was your first Hollywood thing other
than being at doing stand-up but because
you you were saying you were doing other
things other than that and it was
difficult for you and then you had to go
into a different areas um I did a Disney
thing which was really cool that was
like kind of my first like acting kind
of break into it oh [ __ ] maybe I can
maybe I can book some stuff and then
wild it out was definitely like my first
Hollywood like breakout thing no you
went back to your roots when I started a
little bit comfortable because most the
cast mates who I was joining the show
with idea Ray Davis Corey Holcomb Carlos
Melo but I had known those guys since I
was also like 16 years old right in the
early years of while now and you enjoyed
it yeah I had yeah the the live
performances were so much fun
it grew to be something that I didn't
really want my career to be focused like
I didn't want that to be the focus boy
you you can get locked in on that show
you gonna be on that show forever like
you can get trapped because it is a lot
of fun the exposures fantastic yes some
of them are like doing over there doing
this really popular podcast right now
although 85 South 80s out there like
there booble they blew up and now they
do when they torn all over the place
making a kind of money it's a great
outlet like that was the best exposure I
could have gotten because it is a young
urban fanbase and that's kind of what
I've been doing my entire life so it
worked out perfectly for that and I did
three years of it I was starting to be
like alright I don't want to ride a
mechanical bull home like that's not
what I want my career some people when
you got on wiling out that's when you
became an international playboy right
isn't that when that first started ah
absolutely not but it was cool to start
getting recognized by people like that
was something I never thought was really
gonna happen without I remember when you
used to say to me like you did like you
you didn't even have
when I have more Instagram followers
than you and I have a lot yeah you are
so good what am I not just new to I was
like there's this pretty [ __ ]
get on TV it's gonna be like you have
like all those like you have those like
fake Matt ryf account all dude that's
the best fan base to have because young
girls like that they kind of like they
they pick like that heartthrob like what
I'm looking for like they they would die
for you like they they promote for you
they're going out and telling all of
their friends like oh my god is this
really cute funny guy you should go
check him out as well people in their
20s or 30s like that they'll usually
like somebody but they're not like
raving about
I've got girls making like cell phone
cases like t-shirt some had a bedspread
with my face on like that's where's your
store you gotta go further bedspread I
don't feel like I'm at that level yeah I
can get like 20 people to buy some [ __ ]
like that but I want to wait I want to
wait so I'm at a million followers and
it makes sense you like it actually
maybe there's tears too social media
like most people have like why five did
like 10,000 something like that and
that's not even a lot it's not a lot the
average person thinks 10,000 followers
on the Internet is a lot yeah people in
Ohio on my home's out view at 10,000
it's like oh wow okay but then it's
starting to be like you look on
Instagram and it's like there'll be a
hot chick that like you don't know what
she does mhm and she got like 40,000
followers yeah and if you look at that
like what do you what do you do yeah you
know just be a hot girl yeah oh you're
just hot okay cool you know which bomb I
mean capitalize long hey that's your
body do this I am doing the same there
are tears to it though I'm in I'm like
almost a 200,000 now at 200,000 its own
tea or it's like oh you're you're on the
map social media was you can be
considered like a influencer you can
start to make a little bit of money from
it but then like then you ain't [ __ ]
again till like 500,000 to a million
like there's there's different tier
yeah that's yeah to you until you can
get paid to tweet something if somebody
and that it takes like a real high level
people don't understand that like I have
an 80 something thousand whatever no you
know Twitter only like 50,000 and inline
yes on Instagram it's like 80,000 and so
but other people even like like certain
level of comic you know that maybe just
didn't have like notoriety because I
also have workaholics and all that they
don't have that and it's like they think
what I had was a lot it's not yeah most
most comedians I feel like we hang out
with probably have around like like 10
to 20 thousand yeah we even less that's
not bad but if those are your fans
exactly the only problem with having so
many of my fans right now our most of
them are like I wouldn't say it like 50%
of them are like aren't even 18 yet so
it's like but when they do turn 18 I'll
have people who are growing with you you
know absolutely and I really like that
cuz then they get to see me grow as well
they can be like I love people make like
transformations of what I wasn't like 17
or like now I like it make it to see
that because cuz growing with these
people who are around your age and then
they'll still be with you when you get
older yeah which is why you should date
women your own age
that's why you should date women your
own age but you could grow together like
we can't both have the same problem yes
you can there's something about
commiserating with somebody or
supporting somebody at the same time and
you grow together you looking for a home
already a mom who got kids who already
got snacks in them in the [ __ ]
refrigerator you know it does that's not
any growth that's why they all keep
telling you we're not at the same place
alright okay you know cuz then like I
remember like when when did you okay cuz
what's her face was like around your age
and then you start dating and then like
like though they just kept getting older
and older I feel like why do they keep
getting older also I just I don't feel
like I trust younger girls because like
what I get like I said you everybody has
hurt like these like all these old
chicks are coddling you
just like they have are you pride more
over these old chicks than any of these
young chicks
I feel like older older women no matter
how much Odom is this progressively like
that's like the odds of them having
their whole face is already out I feel
like at this point they long were you
huh my point is this my point is this
and I always keep telling you this
you're 25 right for three I keep putting
to echo two extra on it you're 23 mm-hmm
if you're dating somebody say 40 okay
when you're 33 and she's 50 you still
gonna be invested you still go bomb in
love yeah why don't you ask Nick Cannon
about this you should have asked him hey
man how did that work out
Nick Cannon woke up with his auntie if
he was lucky Aston Kutcher how that
worked out I just think the age
appropriate dating is like you know it's
gotta be around that you know me I don't
know I mean who knows I mean I don't
know there's you got to 30 if you were
in your 30s you are established yourself
and then you dating somebody like in
their 40s I'm like that I think that's
fine but you're in your twenties I
understand when I take a step back I
fall in love easily I do yes you do
if I click with someone that I care
about them I'll do whatever you I would
do whatever do you make that person
happy and we're clearing tattoos he does
a lot of dumb stuff yeah out of pain and
love trying to be a nice person
yeah you you you thought I don't know
this guy falls in love so fast like why
like you know sometimes you don't
nothing about them I don't know
sometimes something just clicks man I
don't I don't get I don't get close with
a lot of people like you like I have a
very small close friend group of like
like six people you included that I
trust get my sense of humor understand
where I'm coming from most it's not even
if you see it's [ __ ] you at least
can be like okay I understand she's
thinking so these six people right huh
okay there's been
WAIS as many maybe three times as many
women who you love appreciate you
talking about my number relax it's not
that many girls watching right now da
man you I don't know what it is mates it
gives it's it's weird it gives me a
sense of security and also a massive
insecurity at the same time I say but I
feel like I'm gonna find that with
anybody so I feel like I'm just I'm
picking what feels right at the time and
what I what I what I end up doing is I
had them put end up going all in on
something that I should inevitably know
isn't gonna work I'm saying take a step
take a breath you're right I just again
I'm impatient with everything
I'm very impatient I want to be like
okay this is how it's gonna be
right cool can we set up that could we
figure it all right now and make it yeah
this guy wants to notarize the
relationship that bag gives me a sense
of security a back in home so you feel
someone you see an older woman you see
them have their what you perceive is you
they have their [ __ ] together you think
oh that's what this is gonna make me
feel okay well that says some more about
like how you feeling about your own I
don't feel like I have a sense of
security or stability in my life with
anything because this business you you
know this we're not guaranteed to work
ever again like every day could be our
last job something could happen nobody
just has to work with us it's happened
like like a Brendan Fraser for example I
[ __ ] love Brendan Fraser mommy movies
are you kidding me
monkey boy I love Burnham Fraser working
he was on there but he's not as big as
he was like there's so many different
waves to this and it's like I can go
from like when I was doing TRL making
stupid money to where I could I could go
on a vacation for the first time in my
life I could buy a couple of pair of
shoes and not have to worry about it
even though even though I told your dumb
ass to save your money and I did for the
most I did taxes came gonna be bought a
Mustang I told him to get a Civic you
know but he was like I can't be driving
around with a Mustang I'm on TV like
what I tell you you don't listen I need
to live a life a little bit
Oh
a fine line between being responsible
and enjoying life a little bit man it's
not a fine line there's a fine line
enjoying life and being responsible
they're not in the sense out of it Oh
doubled aw use double dutch I was double
dutch no use getting your feet caught in
the ropes no vacation vacation car
insurance oh my god she'd write you deep
do you have car insurance
no not now oh my god arrest got me so
bad dude they got me so bad for my 2016
tax I got Wesley Snipes it was bad yeah
well this is what I'm talking about
cause you're more saving your money you
know I saved money and then they took
all of all the savings no they took the
tax the tax money isn't that dumb
Mustang that you totaled I just I can't
with you sometimes what you know you
take a shot anybody at home take a shot
he says I can't I'm done with problem
that is your problem you're not gonna
really appreciate everything I'm saying
it's gonna be ten years from now you're
gonna be like you know what man you were
so right and that's what I'm gonna punch
you in the face because I was trying to
help you now you know anyway okay so
well because of all your recent
experiences do you think that like are
you now open to like say let me find a a
23 year old who's you know got they [ __ ]
together I'm calling you know what I'm
calling out right now to all the like
autumn autumn boss boss ladies out there
you and your early 20s you got your [ __ ]
together you got goals and dreams
mid-twenties
okay mid 20s okay you're in your mid-20s
cuz you know he's you know because he
thinks there's no good women out there
and I know that there are I'm not saying
they're not good women I'm saying that's
not for me I know where my insecurities
light and I know what I can't handle and
sometimes I get stuck you know what you
can't handle these relationships with
these old women that's what I'm trying
to tell you
I know because you've been on my couch
sobbing okay so I know you can't handle
it okay so I'm totally right now then
why don't you find somebody where maybe
maybe you don't maybe take the challenge
of you being the rock you ever think
that that can happen that's too much
pressure man
it's all about pressure I know that's
why I'm say it's already my professional
life which is 90% of my life I would
like I just want if I'm gonna be in a
relationship what I'm looking for now
it's just comfortability to a titty you
could just be like yeah man just nuzzle
up to it and just how was your day you
know hopefully hopefully you're gonna
find I'm not in a rush ladies that I'm
23 I don't know were in a rush what are
you talking about I'm not a rush right
now how many times have you wanted to
get married in the last three years
oh man twice probably are you talking
about you don't want to rush and you
already ready to like start a family cuz
that felt comfortable in the moment I
felt comfortable with women with women
who I was very in love with and I wanted
wanted to give my world - and now I'm
like my world is a bit cheaper then than
I thought I was I was gonna have a
budget for emotionally realized
relationship cost money oh and emotions
like I'm stressed that day today trying
to make a career for myself
yeah relationship drama on top of that
quashes look that's why sometimes you
find somebody that was like going
through the same thing you'd be
surprised how that I can generate with
that person into actually I don't see
that yes I mean I would be open to
dating somebody closer to my age and
seeing if our problems can be relatable
for each other we can help push through
them together she back with Big Show I
would say Big Sean yeah yeah well I
guess they back together and sucks I was
hoping your you know I can boost your
career you know you a list celebrity
after that oh man well I don't know I
think that you know relationships are
tough I just broke up I just had a
breakup you know yeah relationships are
tough and especially in this business
especially being in LA it's like hard to
find somebody that can deal with what
you do and even you you you have trouble
you have trouble dating people that are
in the biz
yeah I think so you know cuz just uh
just like you don't like seeing kissing
scenes you don't like yeah I can get
Jess I can get insecure but but I've
realized through dating other people not
everybody's like that I don't feel that
way with everybody it's yeah I have come
to learn that like if I'm if I'm
comfortable in the relationship and I
feel secure with the relationship I
don't worry about that stuff I've
there's been great girls that I've dated
who I've had feelings for but I'm like I
can trust you like if they have to go do
a naked photo shoot with a beautiful guy
model I can be like yeah I don't like
the [ __ ] but like I don't think you're
gonna do anything so it does depend on
the person and I have realized that I've
I've taken therapy before to try to to
figure out what my issues are and how I
can make myself a better person and you
know it's it's a lot of it was on me
many of the times but it's you know
you're also reacting a lot to what
people do not everybody is gonna be for
you yeah I can I can agree with that I
mean I just I feel like you know once
once we put it on ourselves first or
just find out what's our responsibility
in this situation because a lot of times
we'd like to go like they're not making
me feel secure they're not making me
feel this they're doing this is making
me feel this way yeah and sometimes they
are sometimes they are but a lot of it
does lie in your own insecurities yeah
ask it why is that triggering me hmm
right that's the thing is that's the
hard part to like figure out because and
then it's on you
to be like can I handle this and stay in
this relationship or do you win win and
in my case I'd never know when to be
like I can't handle this I need to get
out yeah you yes he does y'all he has a
hard time getting out of [ __ ] but you
know you out of it some relationships
are can be beautiful man it's nice to
have somebody in your corner sometime
it's fun to have somebody to come home
to and you know relax with and relate to
and just just just have fun and joke
around with and and share those emotions
because it's it's far a few between in
this life I know I find it the hard
hardest part especially being in LA I
understand in the LA life is like the
hard part is trying to get to the point
where it's like all right are we gonna
try to trust each other now like that
part and that's the dating that's all
that stuff that part is
that's why I feel like we oftentimes end
up in relationships that maybe they're
not a hundred percent perfect for you
because it's just the searching for a
relationship that part is so frustrating
that being in a not say less than ideal
situation is better than the searching
for yeah you know and and the good in
the honeymoon phase in the beginning
tricks you heart like those first like
six months you're in love you're only
seeing all the good in each other and
then like the sixth like a year and a
half after that you're like okay now I'm
starting to get to know this person yeah
yeah yeah and that that part it is when
people [ __ ] up I feel like one thing I
had to say if I'm jealous of anything is
um you know without saying any names you
know you have had some experiences right
where you're like you can't believe this
person wants to have sex with you there
have been some beautiful girls even I'm
like are you sure like a positive I go
way more invested in me that I believe
in me more than I thought it which is a
shock to me because growing up I wasn't
a cute kid like when you met me I wasn't
like the pretend that is how we describe
it that a cute kid yeah it's the thing
like by no means was I like I'm a
good-looking guy like girl should want
to be with like that that still doesn't
fully register to me yeah but then
you're like yeah but but when I see all
these dumb model shoot pictures that
you're doing looking crazy but like
that's for like that's to appeal to
people who I they are but you know that
but you take care of yourself
that when was it that when was it that
you were like we're working out and
self-maintenance when did that become
such a priority for you um
I think when I was trying to pick a lane
for my career Leigh I didn't know what I
was gonna be I didn't know if I wanted
to be like the the funny scrawny friend
who's like the comic relief or do I want
to be [ __ ] like through do the
shredded one of my favorite actively I I
think I found a passion
and what I want to aim aim my career
towards and I think that's when it
really started to click and then I just
I started to have fun with that I
started to get into a routine and
actually I started to go into the gym
with Dane when I was about like like
nineteen twelve or so in the mornings
and like at that time he and I were kind
of like new friends so it's really just
doing it to kind of be around I know you
like rain have fun with it it became a
routine now if I don't go to the gym for
if I skip a day the next day I have to
go there's so annoying I do it though I
know I did start going to glow but I
gotta go I haven't been able to go in
like a few months just because since
December because you know I went to go
visit my mom and then like I had to
start traveling and all this stuff was
going on but I gotta like I got to find
something else is what I realized it's
like when I'm in town I have time to go
do that I do that but I need like
something that I could do like just get
on the treadmill every day or one of
those types of things but yeah you are
like you are you're in great shape thank
you thank you it's it's a nice feeling
it gives you a confidence boost in
yourself because I mean there's plenty
of people who are good looking but don't
aren't confident in the way they look me
being one of them but it also like
working out is just such a such a stress
reliever like I found myself I can be
going crazy some days it's like you know
what let me go to the gym and box for an
hour where I can't focus on [ __ ] else
like there whooping my ass in there
shameless plug to glove work so check it
out works mix to dream work whatever
cut that out that's good that you use a
net is like I think is pretty problem if
you didn't have that you probably go
crazy
yeah and it's actually it's been really
cool that I've had people like reach out
to me online being like hey what's your
workout my diet routine with my diets
just metabolism but yeah the workout
routes you don't worry that's just gonna
slow down check out my five pack three -
yeah you guys get harder as you get
older but I've had so many people hit me
up it like you're an inspiration I lost
like I've had people be like I've lost a
hundred pounds after seeing how you've
gone from like being so skinny - being a
good shape it gives it an inspiration to
turn my life around I want to say what
people that's really cool people don't
realize that like it's probably easier
for me
to lose 50 pounds than it is for
somebody like that slender to gain this
muscle and get your six-pack and all
that I say yes I've had people argue it
before because I've heard it it depends
on just like the people's body and some
genetic makeup or whatever like some
people it's really impossible for me to
lose weight some people it's impossible
from the game I growing up as a very
skinny kid so for me is like yeah I do
have I take a week off I can start to
lose definition a little bit in light
and like finding sometimes I see
pictures of you I'm like when did he
become a grown-ass man fresh like Paul
I'm not taking like without that it's
funny to me like that you're you know
people just don't realize it like you
still have all these insecurities and
which is what drives you to work and
then at the same time you know get into
these beefs and be hated for you know
yes I'm doing all these things to make
myself better and then every time I get
better there life walk this - who does
he think he is gonna be a better person
I know so there's a lot of hate towards
it but I may have people just squash
your beef but you have what's that kid
Brandon Brandon Brandon Waddell yeah I
don't want beef with a single person
yeah like there's no reason for there's
nobody who I dislike enough to be like I
can I can never make things work with
you I can never be cool that's so dumb
for what
what does it get from me to an IV for
somebody some attentions new cuz you're
like you are still very stubborn about a
lot of things I'm very stubborn stuff I
can I cannot respect you I can not like
the work that you do but that doesn't
mean I want beef it doesn't mean that
like just because I don't think you're
funny or something doesn't mean I have a
problem with you since the humor and P
and judging people's work I think that's
subjective like people like someone's
work ethic and still not think they
funny
exactly you can appreciate why I got
working I don't like them as a person
and not like any of the work that they
put out like it's it's different
variation
yeah so there's no if it was some of our
close friends like I have a lot of close
friends in comedy that like I don't want
to sit and watch their hat don't do it
don't dare save me included I thought
for sure that's totally okay
that's how you talk to me on a weekly
basis three years ago I would just told
you in the earlier of the podcast that I
thought you were funny you guys know in
like 17 more years are you doing yeah
you do again but yeah I think I think
it's so dumb to happy with something you
shouldn't like somebody get to know them
a little bit either get to know them and
then have an opinion about them or just
don't have an opinion at all just like
that's a person in the world who I just
don't really care about so what's next
what do you think
what's the neck what's the next phase
for Matt rice um I've got some exciting
things going on I'm shooting this movie
for a lifetime right now this is I'm
working with Eric Roberts who's a more
the nicest people yeah my toes he's
working he's worked like it's got like
600 yeah he has a whole separate website
he does everything and that's what some
advice he embarked on me as well he was
like don't turn down most roles like
like keep keep a broad range of the
roles you can play there's no point in
pigeonholing yourself like I only do
serious roles or I only do comedy that's
like that's not over 30 right now like
yeah I'm just trying to build resume
show face and get better at what I want
to do for a living we're doing a
Lifetime movie in a lifetime movie I'm
doing a bunch of tour dates with Dane
right now what's the name of Dame's tour
tell like it is to tell it like it is
tour on tour right now and go to Danes
website for that information and then
I'm doing I'm gonna be a part of this
show called it's a new NBC comedy
competition show called bring the funny
Oh lmao this is like the new Last Comic
Standing
I'm not sure I do I don't know too much
about the format at all I just normally
be doing stand-up on there for this
company I think the judges are like like
Jeff Foxworthy
Chrissy Teigen and Kenan Thompson's it
was like a broad range for judges I
think Amanda seals is hosting it so it
should be pretty fun it's a really nice
grand prize
they picked they picked they didn't tell
me into the names of comics but they're
like we want people who are like
established and are really just like you
know
hopefully a breakaway and this will be a
exposure that we need you know hopefully
the next time I have you on it's gonna
be after you've won that grand prize you
know that you could pay me back so you
mean to tell me because I'm on a TV show
that people don't got to pay me back
money that's my singer named Richie
Richie Patty and I a rich man don't even
think that we talking about back a
basic-cable money I don't have Netflix
much a shared Netflix money you know you
still got your MTV and you know you yeah
no man absolutely not if I wasn't
getting these old women and how come you
never got it this is what I this is what
I am respect and also okay I don't
understand it is you giving these old
women they got money and you won't be
they don't even help you and you won't
accept help from them either no cuz
that's not why I'm with somebody I mean
you said you were with them because you
want a stability no I like for them to
have stupid I don't want to have to
worry about other people's problems like
that okay I don't want that I don't want
them to also be broke like me and we're
both struggling with that doesn't that
there's something about the shared
experience I'm telling him I understand
that I don't like accepting help from
people I don't like that I like figuring
stuff out on my own I like to do [ __ ] on
my I feel like if I can't do the [ __ ] on
my own I shouldn't be doing it then then
therefore you did I'm telling you
there's you're gonna meet somebody that
when you have weak moments they'll be
strong and then when in the vice versa
yeah I agree
you know I mean you're gonna find that
just just try it just like with the art
wasn't I right about the art were right
about the I was right about the art
right wasn't i right about saving your
money yes I was right about you should
have everybody I think
but something it's so disgusting to me
that a lot of people do in this town
whether like it doesn't matter what the
person's profession is but like if a lot
of people would get with somebody
because they have money because they
just want handouts for [ __ ] I think
that's one of the most disgusting but
that's
first of all that does not mean that
that's happening if you if you if you
authentically meet someone and build a
genuine authentic connection and
relationship regardless of however much
money they have or not having or
whatever their situation is you can be
secure in that regardless of how it
looks cuz what you're talking about it's
perception yeah you could say that about
people but until you really know how do
you know but I mean that's the society
we live we everyone looks and goes I
think this is what it is Glalie getting
to know anybody but you don't but listen
first of all I don't even find like like
my ex is beautiful model you know I mean
and you know people say well you know
only she's with you because your TV or
whatever and I'm like yeah why do you
think I got on TV like ok I just really
my relationships in the past with women
but we had a genuine connection is what
I'm trying to say yeah so from the
outside you might think that but no I
know what was going on I wasn't you know
doing anything extra it wasn't like you
know you know I know I feel secure in
what we had and I'm saying is I didn't I
don't care about what other people think
yeah I just I just real I really enjoy a
woman with a good head on her shoulders
who has a vision for herself with her
career and her and her okay I like that
what you just said though is that that
doesn't have to be already present them
yes you're right you're absolutely right
that that is what I was trying to
articulate and they begin their life
same journey yet they don't have to have
already made it that's that's dumb I
don't I don't think that's a necessity
whatsoever but you might have been
confusing yourself a little bit that's
why you're like oh look at this mama
bear I mean you find the connection with
these women and they if they some of
them happen to already have a [ __ ]
together some of them absolutely don't
but the mindset behind it the mature
mindset behind is what I'm really
attracted to I think well I'm one time
and I'm trying to tell you in closing is
you'd be surprised to find that there
are women your age who are one gonna be
way more mature than you way more put
together and is exactly what you need in
your life and I hope there is I hope
there is I'm
the contempt and the doubt in his voice
everybody you know but anyways cuz where
we at Aaron oh look at that see right on
the right on the button
a look at that right on the bow what an
hour yeah would you know do you in the
light you know kind of light yeah you
you you're the worst okay Matt is a
monster I'm not that guy you did this
you know I'm surprised me over talking
about it like you cuz he's always
talking about he's gonna drop his dick
pic I had somebody trying to hack my
iCloud this sounds like an exaggeration
I'm being so sincere yeah we single day
since last September every single day I
get a pop up my phone says grant
permission to to request a new password
and I have to click allow or don't allow
on my screen I'm a click away from
[ __ ] myself over I'm giving that
person permission so much how to hack my
[ __ ] every day so it's coming most
likely sorry mom
like I'm I want to delete the dick pics
from my phone but then it's like what I
remember when Bieber but I remember
would be bird this is last story about
you ever beat member like you know he
got caught naked I should drop my dick
pics like dude stop comparing comparing
your dick size with Julie would Bieber
he just a seemed more humid after that
you know I mean I was always a fan and I
was like oh we can be boys like it's
fine I can't believe we're gonna leave
on that I'm just like we did good
friends I don't I don't have a lot of
pedestal anymore like this is like you
know he was you were a champion we did
remember we went to the Bieber comedy
because I had a great time yeah but on a
dope show such a nice guy yeah he's a
cool kid and then we were like in the
like the pit area he was like right
there
yeah I feel like he looked at us a
couple girls are like I didn't know I
was gonna be like that until I he came
to the Laugh Factory uh-huh and then
scooter came and got me he was like hey
B would like to meet you you know and
all he's the president anyway look man
you know you know I love you man you
know you're like family to me only
there's only a few people in the world I
consider like family you're one of them
you have six people I have it's my list
is even smaller and you and that yeah
now yeah you know you know that's real
and I thank you for coming on and I wish
you all the best good luck with the
movie good luck with that
career thank you you know and I do see
big things for you and I honestly say it
when I like I said the last time I saw
you do stand-up when you're with me I
was like oh it was clicking
mm-hm and so I you know and you're young
still like I didn't start doing Stan
until I was 30
hey serious yeah I started at 30 so you
have a look you you have a long way to
go so just keep at it and you're achieve
all your dreams you know and now I say
that to everybody out there to follow
your dreams because it is possible you
know just don't be deterred and work on
your insecurities that's what both of
both Matt and I are doing and you could
do it too and hopefully next time you
know we hear Matt he's gonna be dating
somebody around his age I'm just happy
can I just be happy okay happy you know
with his 47 year old or whatever how old
this chick is gonna be no you're gonna
we're gonna make sure he gives with
somebody who's a so send out those DM
Joe but anyway that's been another great
episode of riffing with Griffin thank
you for all your support everybody
we can't know we we can't play it out
okay you know what we don't play the
theme song around this Marty be where we
get let me get them and get the Marty
beat theme song back up damn it I have
too many where is it here it is thank
you again Marty be ladies and gentlemen
this has been written with Griffin I
want to thank Matt rife my guests are
coming in my brother and thank you for
listening
good night everybody
that's a good night with good evening or
whenever you listen to it by
[Music]